Transcriber: Marah Albakkawi
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
Music
?How are you
A very ordinary sentence
?Isn’t it
?When you ask someone how are you
The answer is always clear
“fine, thank god”
But if you ask a medical student
he probably won’t be able to
express his feelings
This student will not be able to express
What he is going through
And if we ever think and try to talk to
Someone from outside the college
To tell them about our problems
about our concerns
They will often tell you
If you want medicine”
“then you have to endure it
This society is not aware of the danger of
psychological accumulations on
this student
Several studies have been conducted on
medical students in the USA and Norway
showed that the ratios of
suicidal thoughts among medical students
ranged between 11% and 23%
This means that in  all medical schools
in the world, between four people there is
at least one of them has plans and
thoughts to commit suicide
We may not find this thing absurd or
unreasonable
Let’s think, an 18 years old student
if we put him
in some circumstances
such as isolation from people
away from every thing
hard conditions for study
and poor academic attainment in sometimes
This means that the teaching method
contributes to this
and we have to pay attention to the matter
We have to pay attention to the teaching
Method influence on this subject
Now, I was always thinking to make this
change
but my notion of change and my journy
in it have started in 2012
when my father passed away after
being admitted to the hospital
In porpose to have splenectomy
he died as a result of medical negligence
my father went to this hospital and
developed acondition known as
disseminated intravascular coagulation
or DIC
it means clots in some of body’s arteries
that leads to platelet consumption
Later, my father went into a coma
and passed away as a result of that
From there on, a storm hit all of my past
and made me a new man
one of his most precious principle
is the change
To prevent darkness from entering
anew home
to prevent darkness from
new medical negligence
I tried to transform all the sadness and
deficit energy to a form of energy
able to change and make something new
but when I enter the faculty
I shocked by teaching methods
which are still in all medical
faculties around the world
the methods still traditional
it depends only on memorizing and storing
if I asked you all ,what is
the different between info and knowledge
what is the different of having info and
?knowledge
the info now is for everyone
medical and technological advances cause
that the medical info is available for
everyone, but knowledge is how to use
these info and using these facts
to help people and to make something new
and to make a change
,but unfortunately this is not followed
in most of medical faculties around
the world
Usually the student is not so employed
for example, more in treatment
and not used so much in teaching
for this reason I talked about
?how can I make a change
from this point I start to ask and search
usually, some university state that you
should allowed the medical student
to participat more in patients therapy
this is something alot of hospitals fear
from
fear from medical error
the surprise was that many studies on
this topic
reveal that percentage of error
in teaching hospital are much less
that because the responsible doctors
are on highly degree of alertness
so the medical error will be much less
than before
I am still searching on how can I
make a change
how can I change
the environment and society I am in
In my sixth year of study
at first I created a mini-union
and its function was like this
sixth and fifth year students will teach
the students from the fourth year
wether about clinical information
or about the medical history
or other aspects
we finished this course with
a mini-practical exam for all the students
there were over sixty students
here was the surprise that I start
to realize
the students who took apart
in this training all agreed
that their education level
became higher after this training
but the most importent point was
in the trainers themselves
they said that their knowledge inhanced
they became more confident in themselves
that’s because the best way to learn
is to teach
this is why I always
insist that we should use the students in
education to make a difference
to do something bigger
and to improve this subject
In 2020, and during the quarantine which
we all been through
my colleagues and I, one of them is
Laith Azzam
established CLINICS
Clinics is an institution its purpose was
to change medical education in the country
I’d like to tell you that until my
standing here on this stage
we have presented more than 350
hours of training
have been done in different parts of
the country
we were in Jerusalem, we were in Khalil
in Bethlehem
in Nablus, in Ramallah
everywhere
we did a training for most of the students
on the other hand, I had in this page
students from second, third and fourth
years who worke on providing medical
content
they are the ones who contribute in
giving this medical content
and educating their colleagues
and educating their friends
they all agreed on the following things
first, their confidence in themselves
increased
their educational attainment became
greater
and their confidence in their mental
health became better
what I am talking about
the thing I am trying to convey is
that to use the students to teach others
which mean to use the students to
educate themselves
this will enhance the psychological
state of all students
In addition to that, you are giving him
a social value
a value among all the students
around him
by doing this, the level of education
will raise up
the student will stay all the time
in touch with his knowledge
all the time in contact with it
for this, you will also elevate the level
of knowledge
what I am trying to pinpoint is that
something you can use in all colleges
not only in medical schools
we can change the reality
We as young people can change the reality
from every momment in this change
.Thank you